and now please welcome two-time Academy
Award winner Hilary Swank
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
John Huston Billy Wilder Steven
Spielberg and Clint Eastwood to name
just a few
last year history was made when for the
first time a woman joined their ranks of
oscar-winning directors and she is with
us tonight please welcome Academy Award
winner Kathryn Bigelow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this year we've seen many memorable
films made by profoundly talented
filmmakers we celebrate and honor their
work tonight the nominees for
achievement in directing are Darren
Aronofsky Black Swan David O'Russell the
fighter Tom Hooper the King's Speech
David Fincher the social network Joel
Cohen and Ethan Coen true grit and the
Oscar goes to Tom Hooper the King's
Speech
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Tom Hooper
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
thank you to all the members of the
Academy this is an extraordinary honor
I'd like to congratulate my fellow
nominees Darrin David David Earl and
Ethan your work this year has been
extraordinary and I'm honored to be
nominated alongside you thank you to my
my wonderful actors the triangle the
triangle of man love which is Colin
Firth Geoffrey Rush and me I'm only here
because of you guys and had an I hope
that reference doesn't make you too
jealous thank you to all my cast to my
wonderful crew to my producers in Gareth
amel to David Seidler whose
extraordinary journey from childhood
stammer to the stage of the Kodak I find
so profoundly moving but most of all
thank you to my parents my mum and dad
who are in the audience tonight and I
know there's been a lot of thanking of
mums but this is slightly different
because my mum in ninth in 2007 was
invited by some Australian friends she's
Australian in London to a fringe theater
play reading of an unproduced
unrehearsed play called The King's
Speech now she's never been invited to
play reading in her life before she
almost didn't go because it didn't sound
exactly promising but thank God she did
because she came home rang me up and
said Tom I think I found your next film
so with this tonight I honor you and the
moral of the story is listen to your
mother
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]